à 12 ans j'ai eu le droit d'
à mon premier
à la maison parce
lors d'un pari c'est pas que j'étais un
très bon joueur mais mon père était un
joueur encore pire que moi à 16 ans sont
arrivés les premiers ordinateurs qui
savait jouer aux échecs et ses
ordinateurs battait mon père à tous les
coups et moins il battait disons trop
souvent j'étais en première c'est l'âge
où on commence à lire baudelaire edgar
poe est justement edgar poe a écrit une
nouvelle fascinante sur le jeu d'échecs
qui s'appelle le joueur d'échecs de
médecins il s'agit en fait d'une sorte
d' arnaque aux échecs
une petite machine qui est présenté
comme un automate sachant jouer aux
échecs dans laquelle en réalité est
caché un an
le premier ordinateur mécanique venait
d'être inventé et gares pose une
question stupéfiante il dit est-ce que
c'est plus facile au fond d'avoir une
meute de concevoir une machine qui est
capable de calculer à toute vitesse des
milliers d'opérations rythme éthique un
ordinateur ou d'avoir une machine qui
s'est joué aux échecs et immédiatement
il conclut que c'est totalement
impossible d'avoir une machine qui
sais-je aux échecs
parce qu'il faut prendre en compte tout
le contexte le coup d'après le joueur
adverse et c'est alors qu'on peut
concevoir une machine qui sait calculer
à toute vitesse et eddie une machine qui
saurait jouer aux échecs est totalement
impossible
et si elle existe et ce serait la plus
extraordinaire invention de l'humanité
l'année d'après mon prof de philo on a
remué une dos sur l'ordinateur qui ne
savaient pas penser qu'il n'était qu'un
outil et qui est évidemment dépassé par
l'être humain sur les animaux qui comme
disait descartes étaient des machines
programmées uniquement par leur instinct
et qui donc n'avait aucune intelligence
ou du moins dans l'intelligence
présenter une différence de nature avec
l'intelligence humaine et moi j'avais
sous les yeux mon chien qui tous les
jours sans vouloir infirmer les
conclusions que des cartes et j'avais un
ordinateur qui savait jouer suffisamment
bien aux échecs pour me battre c'est là
où j'ai voulu commencer à
comprendre tout ça et où j'ai appris à
programmer pour savoir d'où sortait
finalement cette intelligence ou s'était
trompé descartes peau et accessoirement
mon prof de philo vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui les ordinateurs bat
couramment même le champion du monde aux
échecs
même quand les programmes sont
développées par des programmeurs qui
sont très moyens aux jeux d échecs
lui-même donc la question qui se pose
c'est où l intelligence si ce n'est dans
la machine et la révolution numérique
c'est ça c'est quand l'intelligence
finalement on est obligé d'admettre
qu'elle est à l'intérieur de la machine
ça se passait dans les années 90 depuis
les choses vraiment importantes qui sont
plus ou moins importantes qui sont
arrivés d'abord les ordinateurs ont
multiplié leur vitesse de calcul par un
facteur entre 100000 1 million est sacré
ce qu'on appelle la révolution numérique
et puis sur un plan plus personnel j'ai
fondé une famille
j'ai eu deux enfants j'ai eu un nouveau
chien et en 2005 j'ai créé mon
entreprise
speechi dont but est justement
d'utiliser ces nouvelles technologies
numériques pour améliorer l'école et
qu'est-ce qui m'a immédiatement marqué
quand j'ai lancé cette entreprise c'est
que finalement l'école depuis 15 ans
essaye d'apprendre aux enfants comment
se servir des technologies numériques
on leur distribue des tablettes des
ordinateurs des tableaux interactifs que
sais-je encore mais elle ne leur
apprends pas comment ces machines sont
programmés conçus développés penser en
gros l'école s'est concentré sur les
usages plutôt que de se concentrer sur
les principes c'est à dire la
programmation qui est au coeur de ces
machines ce faisant elle fait sans doute
complètement fausse route
parce que ce qui est important pour les
enfants pour la maîtrise du monde qui
les entoure c'est de comprendre les
principes sait encore exactement comme
si pour apprendre le fonctionnement
d'une voiture on faisait passer aux gens
uniquement leur permis de conduire
ça nous aiderait pas comprendre comment
les voitures roulent au fonctionne
l'école est devant une tâche difficile
parce que c'est déjà difficile pour elle
en ce moment d'apprendre à lire écrire
compter
mais finalement elle devrait apprendre à
lire écrire compter est programmé ce qui
est un objectif de plus les enfants
aujourd'hui doivent apprendre les
algorithmes il doit apprendre comment
les concevoir comment les coder comment
les programmer et donc c'est ça l'enjeu
l'enjeu de l'école aujourd'hui aux états
unis
on sait tous à 90 % des étudiants de
sciences po suivre suivent une formation
très avancées en programmation
informatique de niveau plus avancé sous
certains aspects que les problèmes
d'informatique qu'on donne aux étudiants
de nos de nos écoles d'ingénieurs et le
but les pas du tout pour devenir des
informaticiens sont des étudiants en
sciences po le but c'est vraiment
d'améliorer leur compte la compréhension
du monde d'aujourd'hui
à chaque époque il ya eu sa matière au
moyen-âge vous avez le latin qui a
permis qu'il qui donne l'accès à la
religion au droit à la médecine la
culture à l'époque de la révolution
industrielle
c'est à dire quand les forces des
machines ont remplacé les bras humain et
la force animale à l'époque de la
révolution industrielle
vous avez eu l'essor des sciences à
l'école les mathématiques les sciences
physiques
toutes ces sciences qui sert finalement
à améliorer les techniques de production
des machines elle même à les faire
progresser
aujourd'hui à l'époque de la révolution
numérique c'est à dire au moment où les
cerveaux artificiels sont en train de
remplacer les cerveaux humains et ben
informatique
aso centre il ne s'agit pas de créer une
génération d'informaticiens pas plus
qu'il ne s'agissait de créer une
génération de latinistes ou une
génération de mathématiciens encore une
fois il s'agit simplement de donner aux
élèves le moyen de maîtriser le monde
qui les entoure alors il ya autre chose
qui s'est passé
simultanément durant ces quinze ou vingt
dernières années
c'est que l'informatique est devenue une
science fondamentale ce qu'elles
n'étaient pas auparavant fondamental ça
veut dire qu'elle a infusé dans toutes
les sciences et qu'elle est
indispensable à la maîtrise de la
plupart des sciences de la les cas les
plus connues sont la médecine et la
biologie mais c'est vrai aussi qu'en
physique en chimie
si je prends par exemple prix nobel 2013
de chimie il a été donnée non pas pour
une découverte fondamentale en chimie
mais il a récompensé un algorithme un
programme conçu dans les années 70 ce
qui permet finalement un chimiste de fer
sur son ordinateur
l'équivalent de ce qu'ils faisaient
avant dans son kibboutz et de simuler
une réaction chimique de a à z de façon
extrêmement précise
dans les années 70 ce programme était
totalement inutile parce qu' il fallait
des semaines parfois des mois ou des
années pour simuler des réactions très
simple mais avec l'explosion de la
puissance des machines
les chimistes s'en servent aujourd'hui
pour simuler des centaines de milliers
de réactions la foi et donc le meilleur
chimiste aujourd'hui c'est plus celui
qui regarde son tube à essai changer de
couleur c'est celui qui conçoit le
meilleur algorithme pour simuler des
dizaines de milliers de réactions
intéressantes et sans doute aussi le
meilleur algorithme pour sélectionner
parmi toutes ces simulations
quelles sont les réactions quand on
réellement réussi quelles sont celles
qui ont eu un bon rendement
quelles sont celles qui ont été atypique
et on voit bien comment la lourde
l'algorithmie finalement modifie même
les sciences les plus fondamentales
alors quelles sont les conséquences de
tout ça pour nos enfants pour l'école
finalement d'abord nos enfants comme
nous sont entourés d'objets programmés
et c'est quelque chose qui va continuer
à augmenter
mais face à ces objets ils sont dans une
position de consommateurs passifs pour
ne pas dire parfois de proie un enfant
qui va sur google et vues par google
comme une ressource publicitaire google
cherche à lui servir le meilleur
bandeaux publicitaires possible et c'est
très efficace puisque vous savez on sait
qu'un enfant passe moins d'une minute
sur google avant de cliquer sur une
publicité sur facebook si je prends
l'exemple de facebook c'est exactement
la même chose
l'enfant est finalement vu comme un
clavier vivant il rentre des données qui
vont permettre à facebook de le cibler
parfaitement
ainsi sur facebook que toute sa
communauté d'amis donc finalement
l'enfant est prisonnier d'interface
utilisateur qui ont été conçus par
d'autres programmeurs il est il en est
un peu esclave et le choix de l'école
pour les enfants l'enjeu c'est est ce
que nos enfants seront programmés ou est
ce qu'ils seront programmées
qu'est ce qu'on a fait nous de notre
côté il ya deux mois on a créé le
premier cursus informatique destiné aux
collèges qui permet d'apprendre
l'informatique avec des robots ce cursus
commencent à être diffusés dans
l'éducation nationale puisque depuis
quelques mois
l'informatique au sens de la
programmation est au programme du
collège et on va aussi créer dans les
trois prochaines années 500 écoles sur
toute la france
alors qu'est ce qu'on enseigne dans ces
écoles je dirais il ya deux mots clés
c'est ludique et concret ludique parce
que les enfants sont ravis de jouer
finalement avec ses robots de les
construire les faire bouger
les robots sont munis de capteurs qui
leur permet de prendre en compte leur
environnement et donc les enfants
adorent ça concret parce que on essayait
de tirer tous nos exemples de
l'environnement des enfants de la vie de
tous les jours
les enfants font des voitures
intelligentes des voitures son pilote
des algorithmes qui empêchent les
véhicules de rentrer les uns dans les
autres
des aspirateurs qui vont partout des
robots qui arrange qui savent prendre
les objets les ranger on a aussi pas mal
d'exemples qui sont sortis de
l'observation de la nature
on a tout un cursus sur la marche
comme par exemple ce petit chien
et donc finalement couché allez les
enfants programme dans l'ensemble de
leur cursus
une cinquantaine de robots qui leur
rapporte quelque chose c'est la
compréhension des objets connectés
programmés qui sont dans leur
environnement
le but de ces cours n'est pas un but
professionnel
le but de ces c'est exactement comme
quand vous inscrivez votre enfant un
cours de piano
le but n'est pas qu'ils deviennent un
musicien professionnel mais développer
certaines qualités artistiques
d'oreilles de lecture de partitions mais
là c'est exactement la même chose on
cherche avant tout à lui faire
développer trois grandes qualités qui
sont nécessaires pour comprendre
l'informatique ou que permet d'acquérir
la compréhension de l'informatique
la première chose c'est la capacité à
résoudre des problèmes les enfants sont
devant des briques des cartes
électroniques des moteurs des capteurs
et ils doivent résoudre un problème par
eux-mêmes penser par eux-mêmes pour
arriver au résultat
la deuxième chose c'est la pensée
critique tout ce qu'ils ont fait
l'informatique le savent d'ailleurs même
ceux qui ont passé d'informatique le
savent
un programme ne marche jamais du premier
coup un programme
l'enfant se retrouve face à un objet qui
devrait marcher mais qui ne fonctionne
pas et donc il doit critiquer son
raisonnement
ça c'est très utile et d'ailleurs c'est
d'autant plus utile que l'école
française apprend très peu à faire ça et
la troisième chose c'est la pensée
créative
parce que même pour un problème très
simple en informatique il ya 500 façon
de le résoudre et donc on voit très bien
très vite comment les enfants
développent leur propre style leur
propre capacité à résoudre des problèmes
c'est différent entre tous entre tous
les enfants ce cap hier les enfants
finalement c'est la capacité du monde la
compréhension intuitive des objets
connectés autour d'eux un savoir aussi
très rapidement que leurs parents ne
connaissent pas parce que dès les
premiers cours les enfants sont capables
de comprendre des choses sur les robots
qui vont rester très très obscur pour
les pour les parents
et donc ce bien il est vraiment c'est un
gars en connaissance c'est un gain
culturel j'insiste sur le mot culturel
parce que d'habitude on justifie
l'enseignement de l'informatique sous
l'angle professionnels alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui un bon informaticien dans
tous les pays du monde est protégée
contre le contre le chômage n'est là on
parle de cours qui sont qui s'adresse à
des enfants qui sont collèges ou lycées
et l'esprit de l'école française de
l'école de juste de jules ferry n'est
pas de considérer que les enfants sont
des outils humain qu'on prépare le mieux
possible à l'entreprise voit
l'environnement industriel dans lequel
ils vont travailler une dizaine d'années
plus tard le but de l'école c'est de
créer des citoyens libres indépendants
capables de comprendre le monde capables
si possible si possible d'y avoir un
impact pour que pour faire progresser
l'ensemble de la société et pour paix
rhdp pour perpétuer la réalité de la de
la démocratie c'est pour ça qu'on a
appelé nos écoles algues aura algo pour
les algorithmes et agoras en hommage à
l'école d'athènes à la transmission du
savoir classique et à la démocratie il
faut faire passer l'informatique au
coeur de la cité la france a beaucoup de
retard dans ce domaine
un quart de la planète est connecté au
web et seuls ceux qui savent programme
et peuvent agir
merci